no
[Música]
nosotros los seres humanos tenemos
muchas cosas en común con las estrellas
que vemos en el cielo por ejemplo el ser
humano pasa los primeros 9 meses de su
existencia en el interior del seno
materno oculto a la vista del mundo
exterior ha sido solo en las últimas
décadas que la medicina ha desarrollado
técnicas como por ejemplo el ultrasonido
que permiten ver conviviendo y un humano
va creciendo si es que tiene alguna
enfermedad si es que tiene alguna
deficiencia y esto ha sido
extraordinariamente útil algo similar ha
ocurrido en el caso de las estrellas
resulta que las estrellas se forman en
unas gigantescas nubes que existen en el
espacio y esas nubes son oscuras no nos
dejan ver lo que hay adentro pero
afortunadamente en las últimas décadas
se han desarrollado mucho nuevas
astronomía como la radio astronomía o la
astronomía infrarroja que nos permiten
qué ocurre dentro de esas nubes y
finalmente poder ver cómo se da el
proceso de la formación de nuevas
estrellas y cómo vamos a ver junto con
ellas nuevos planetas también resulta
que estas grandes nubes están sujetas a
la fuerza de gravedad la fuerza de
gravedad trata de comprimir las cosas y
finalmente lo logra ser y un fragmento
de esa nube se contrae y da lugar a una
estructura en rotación en cuyo centro
está el cuerpo que va a ser la estrella
y alrededor es una hay una especie de
estructura aplanada que gira alrededor
de la estrella que por lo aplanada que
está y lo circular le llamamos un disco
y le llamamos para más detalle un disco
protoplanetario porque de ese disco se
van a ir formando los nuevos planetas
entonces una estrella joven es muy
distinta a una estrella vieja o una
estrella madura como es el caso del sol
entonces afortunadamente en los últimos
20 años hemos podido ya observar cómo en
estas estrellas jóvenes no tienen aún
planetas pero tienen el llamado disco
protoplanetario que pensamos poco a poco
va a irse condensado en partículas cada
vez más grandes hasta dar lugar a nuevos
a nuevos planetas cuando estudiamos
estos discos encontramos que algunos de
ellos como el que les muestro en esta
imagen obtenida por nuestro grupo aquí
en morelia son discos a los que les
falta la parte interior y ustedes dirán
por qué falta esa parte interior bueno
pues aquí
es porque ahí se han formado ya planetas
y el gas que había en el disco ha
desaparecido bueno no ha desaparecido se
ha transformado en planetas que son
puntitos y son muy difíciles de detectar
entonces estamos increíblemente viendo
no solo el nacimiento de una nueva
estrella y de planetas sino la evolución
de este sistema hasta transformarse en
algo que pensamos va a ser similar a
nuestro propio sistema solar con una
estrella en el centro y planetas girando
a su alrededor ustedes me dirán bueno y
esto se ha confirmado que existen
planetas definitivamente si uno de los
resultados más importantes de la
astronomía contemporánea es que
alrededor de la mayoría de las estrellas
que vemos en el cielo de la mayoría de
las estrellas que podemos estudiar los
astrónomos hay planetas es algo
increíble hace 20 años no sabíamos la
respuesta a esta pregunta ahora sabemos
que los planetas o mejor dicho los
exoplanetas como se les llama
para diferenciarlos de los ocho planetas
de nuestro sistema solar a estos
planetas alrededor de otras estrellas se
les llama exoplanetas planetas externos
a nuestro sistema solar estos son muy
fresco y comunes hasta ahora la
experiencia es que la mayoría son
bastante distintos a la tierra pero hay
muchos que se parecen a la tierra el
siguiente paso va a ser entender toda
esta secuencia de cambio a través del
tiempo y estudiar a estos exoplanetas
estudiar su atmósfera ver si algunos de
ellos pudieran ser habitables o
inclusive algunos de ellos podrían estar
habitados por algún tipo de bacteria o
de organismo microscópico o de cuerpos
más grandes no sabemos la respuesta a
esta pregunta tan importante para
nosotros si estamos solos o no en el
universo no la sabemos pero digamos que
la gran frecuencia la gran cantidad de
exoplanetas sugiere una respuesta en el
sentido de que no sé qué habrá
posiblemente vi de nosotros
pero el científico no se puede adelantar
a las conclusiones habrá que hacer
mediciones y las décadas futuras nos
darán la respuesta a esta pregunta
también tan importante
quisiera yo terminar diciendo que las
estrellas y los seres humanos en
realidad estamos muy vinculados como les
decía yo el material que nos forma a
nosotros tiene carbono calcio en los
huesos hierro en la sangre fósforo y
todos esos elementos vienen de estrellas
que existieron en el pasado el universo
cuando empezó era solamente de los dos
elementos químicos más sencillos el
hidrógeno y el helio y tuvo que haber
unas primeras generaciones de estrellas
que tomaron estos elementos y los
transformaron en elementos más pesados
como los que les decía yo y ya las
siguientes generaciones de estrellas se
pudieron formar de una manera tal que se
pudieron formar planetas rocosos como la
tierra en ellos habría agua hidrógeno y
oxígeno
al menos en la tierra el fenómeno
increíble de la vida ahora sabemos que
nuestro planeta tiene muchos problemas
ocasionados en buena parte por el ser
humano y que pudiera haber una
catástrofe en el futuro relativamente
cercano esperemos que no ocurra porque
habita el único planeta al que tenemos
acceso es la tierra lo tenemos que
cuidar la posibilidad de irse a otro
planeta externo está en el futuro muy
remoto y va a ser muy difícil
tecnológicamente pero aún si logramos
sobrevivir a esta crisis casi inmediata
que enfrenta la tierra y el ser humano
sabemos que va a haber otros límites el
sol se va a pagar esto se va a pagar en
5 mil millones de años y vamos a tener
que si queremos que la cultura humana
permanezca va a haber que pensar en
pasar a una parte de la humanidad una
parte obviamente muy pequeña por lo
costoso que es mover las cosas en el
espacio aún
un nuevo exoplaneta con una estrella más
joven y que allí pudiera seguir la
existencia humana entonces
increíblemente venimos de las estrellas
y todo parece indicar que regresaremos a
ellas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]